les metaves l'idée n'est pas nouvelle
mais on en a rarement autant parler
surtout depuis que la maison mère de
facebook annoncé son changement de nom
pour devenir méta ce changement est
censé refléter la nouvelle obsession de
Mark Zuckerberg pour les univers sociaux
immersifs que sont les metaves un choix
qui coûte cher et qui rapporte peu des
milliards de dollars en perte en 2022 ce
qui a plombé le moral des investisseurs
mais malgré tout the queburg garde le
cap convaincu que l'univers virtuel des
méta verts représente non seulement
l'avenir du Web mais aussi l'avenir de
l'humanité ni plus ni moins on a voulu
cette semaine de plonger dans cet
univers question dans mesurer la portée
Nicolas les fameux Métavers devenus le
mantra de Mark Zucker qui entretient de
grandes ambitions à cette matière là on
y reviendra au lissant on voit ça un peu
partout mais commençons par définir ce
que c'est un métavère pour que tout le
monde comprenne mais à sa plus simple
expression là c'est un monde l'heure
actuelle ou des gens se réunissent donc
maintenant on en parle beaucoup sur un
associé social du vrai monde qui se
réunit dans un monde virtuel donc quand
on parle du métabar aujourd'hui on peut
imaginer que moi je suis dans ce monde
virtuel là avec un avatar qui me
représente et avec toi on irait ensemble
dans une salle de cinéma avec d'autres
avatars dans ce métabolisme
pour aller écouter un film tous ensemble
on va peut-être parler en même temps
après ça on irait peut-être au magasin
s'acheter des vêtements virtuels pour
vos avatar avec de l'argent on paierait
vraiment pour ces vêtements-là par la
suite on pourrait aller ensemble à une
galerie d'art promener observer des
toiles et finalement on termine la
journée dans une salle de réunion avec
le reste de l'équipe de décrypteur pour
parler de notre émission par exemple et
tout ça ce confort de notre salon
probablement avec un casque de réalité
virtuelle c'est pas obligatoire mais en
ce moment qu'on en parle c'est beaucoup
avec des caisses de réalité virtuelle
qui se passe ce que tu décris
monsieur
vouloir donner l'impression qu'il est le
grand manitou de tout ça mais ça
existait depuis un certain temps
progresser même existait non oui le
principe même existait si on pense à des
jeux comme World of Warcraft par exemple
des gens se réunissaient dans cet
univers là avec leurs avatars c'est un
jeu comme ça qu'une Life qui existe
encore depuis très longtemps avec un peu
ce même concept-là et même aujourd'hui
ça existe sous différentes formes si
mettent à l'heure donc pour la salle de
cinéma par exemple il y a des jeunes
applications qui s'appelle big screen où
on peut aller plus des films tous
ensemble avec du monde il y a déjà
l'application horizon work rooms on peut
faire des réunions virtuelles c'est une
application de méthode justement de
Facebook et finalement il y a aussi le
jeu ou le métaver principal de facebook
s'appelle alrison World qui est un
espèce de grand univers ou même créé des
mondes et on peut se promener à rentrer
d'autres gens il y a un chat qui existe
également toutes sortes de Métavers qui
existent dans leur propre coin mais la
grande vision de marzorkerberg c'est le
métaver avec un grand l là qui réunirait
tous ces petits méta vers là sous un
même toit et qui serait interopérable
qui communique entre je pourrais
facilement communiquer par exemple d'un
étagère à un autre mais aussi que notre
avatar on partage de mettre à l'heure à
l'autre donc je pouvais maintenant les
mêmes vêtements parce que par exemple je
pourrais des vêtements virtuels qu'on
achète qu'on pourrait avoir deux
méthodes à l'autre ou même on parle
beaucoup des jeux vidéo dans tout ça
parce que ultimement c'est des jeux
vidéo ben peut-être qu'on garderait un
accessoire d'un jeu à l'autre dans ce
métal vert là donc c'est une idée qui
est très ambitieuse et on pourrait
penser peut-être que c'est réaliste
quand on pense au fait que les
compagnies technologies sont très
protectrices de la propriété
intellectuelle et beaucoup de
concurrence entre elles mais il y a un
consortium le World webcomsorium qui a
unifié l'expérience navigation sur
Internet qui travaille présentement à
définir des paramètres communs pour tous
ces métador là pour peut-être qu'ils
soient mis ensemble et il y a toutes
sortes d'applications intéressantes à
tout ça bug il veut peut-être qu'on
porte des casques de réalité mixte pour
que il y ait des éléments du métaver
qu'on apporte dans la vraie vie et
vice-versa donc un casque qui serait
comme en réalité augmentée on verra
peut-être un objet qu'on possède dans le
métabolaire et il y a d'autres
applications intéressante pour ça
notamment éducative culturelle comme
nous l'explique mon bon enfant titulaire
de la chair de recherche en donner
massive et en communauté joueur en
ouvrant ce type d'univers là on peut
aussi
ouvrir à certaines formes de
diffusion de la culture et de la
connaissance et je précise on peut très
bien imaginer des musées qui offrent des
expositions des théâtres qui offrent des
pièces mais on peut aussi penser à des
écoles qui ouvriraient des classes des
conférences des universités qui
offriraient des cours et où les gens
pourraient aller accéder à la via leur
avatar bon tous ces prometteurs c'est
bien beau pour pour ceux qui aspirent à
ce genre de réalité virtuelle ou non
mais on en est où dans tout ça en ce qui
concerne notamment mettant les projets
de Mark Zuckerberg qui comme on le sait
à pas mal de moyens pour mettre ses
plans exécution mais jusqu'à maintenant
ça se passe pas très bien
des documents internes de méthodes qui
ont été dévoilées par le wattre
récemment donc dans le métaver principal
de Facebook le jeu ryzen World mettait
ça devrait avoir 500 000 utilisateurs
actifs d'ici la fin de l'année
présentement ils sont à moins de 200000
et seulement 9 % des mondes dans ryzen
World ont été visités par plus de 50
joueurs et en plus de ça la plupart ne
restent pas plus d'un mois dans le jeu
donc jusqu'à maintenant c'est un monde
assez vide et même les concurrents comme
vieux chat tout ce que life aurait plus
d'utilisateurs actifs à n'importe quel
moment donner que horizon words mais bon
ça veut pas dire que c'est un échec pour
autant parce que c'est pas un départ
canon comme le respect c'est pas un
départ canon mais il se donne au moins 5
à 10 ans pour développer ce ce métabère
là et maintenant c'est encore ses
premiers balbutissements donc on peut
pas encore parler de grands échecs mais
c'est sûr que ça va pas super bien il y
a aussi eu beaucoup d'articles qui ont
été écrits par rapport au har beaucoup
de joueurs beaucoup de joueuses plus
faibles des femmes et il y a d'autres
aspects de problématiques à tout ça qui
sont peut-être pas encore là mais au bon
enfant elle est très inquiète de nature
commerciale de tout ça le modèle de
Zuckerberg et basé sur la collecte
massive de données personnelles avec
toutes les risques de manipulation et là
on peut parler des adultes mais là ça
serait aussi les enfants donc on imagine
à long terme qu'est-ce que ça pourrait
faire comme comme type de
conditionnement à des comportements
d'achat ou même manipulation des idées
politiques vraiment être idéaliste et
vraiment
utopisme on se dirige ça devrait être un
organisme tel que l'ONU un consortium
tel que le worldwide web qui viennent
nous proposer un métrage public non
propriétaires ouverts les Juifs encadrés
et où les enfants les ados sont protégés
bon ce cadre là ce cadre normatif
souhaité par Madame Bonnenfant on en
voit peut-être les premiers jalons au
lancement oui avec le regrette qu'on qui
est tantôt mais bon on verra à quel
point que ce sera important dans tout ce
qui pourront avoir un rôle de premier
plan dans tout ça est-ce que ce serait
plutôt peut-être en arrière plan et
finalement ce sera des compagnies
privées comme méthode qui vont contrôler
tout ça on continue de suivre ça au
crypto en attendant on met nos casques
de réalité virtuel on y va allons-y